all right is it working all right it's
working this time what up guys welcome
to the just pearly things YouTube
channel and welcome
um to
I don't know news updates I guess
um so what are we going to talk about
today
Andrew Tate
uh so uh we are going
oh sorry I don't know if you need
anything
um okay so today we are going to talk
about Andrew Tate um has been officially
charged with grape and human trafficking
so we're gonna go over
guys just how biased this fake new CNN
media is
um so for those of you that don't know
which I'm sure everyone here does
the last year basically they have been
trying to dig up any information they
can on Andrew Tate they have been going
through everybody he knows trying to
find a crime that they can pin it on pin
they can pin on him
uh pretty much because he's just too
powerful too influential and
foreign
I don't know I mean when you think about
it they he really stands for all of the
things that meet the media hates the
media doesn't want you know I mean the
Matrix one wants to keep you broke they
want to keep you lazy they want to keep
you stupid and Tay advocates for men to
take control of their own lives not to
tolerate
you know bad women bad men and to make
money be strong be masculine and you
guys already know that the mainstream
media just does not more volume Pearl
can you guys hear me can you hear me
blessing
sorry guys One Second Blessing can you
fix
hold on let me let me text blessing
sorry guys
uh they're saying
my volume is low
uh but today we're gonna go through
um first I'm gonna show you guys the BBC
article and then we're gonna go through
uh I don't
Solomon
ahmeds and we're going to go through his
Twitter thread on the case because
I think he covers it a lot more fairly
but you know I'm just you know just to
be balanced we're going to show both of
the ways that you know the the fake news
media and you know these days Twitter
has better reporting that is the state
of the media Twitter and YouTube has
better reporting than these people
um and then we're gonna go through the
Tate tweets so guys buckle up uh can you
guys hear me because
I wanna
I wanna make sure let's see let's see
also guys like the video that's the most
important metric that YouTube uses uh to
push out these live streams so if you
are
interested
in pushing out these live streams please
like the video
blessing come back
let me just see
the very good audio is good hey they're
saying the audio's low
okay we'll be there okay
um all right so uh we're gonna start
while blessing comes back with the BBC
the
you know
okay we can fix it the ssrc
oh they're they're telling me it's slow
I don't know
okay so today we're going to start with
how does
the honest
traditional media cover this case so it
says Andrew Tate charged with grape I'm
gonna say grape just for YouTube and
human trafficking so
this was by Lucy Williamson so for those
of you that don't know Lucy is the one
who did the Andrew Tate BBC interview
um that was very let's just be honest
that was it was just a live hit piece in
real time so
controversial influencer Andrew Tate has
been charged in Romania with grape human
trafficking and forming an organized
crime group to sexually exploit women
his brothers and two Associates face
charges all have denied the allegations
the Tate brothers were first arrested at
their Buddha
Bucharest home in December in March they
moved they were moved from custody to
house arrest following a ruling by
Romanian judge the indictment depth
deposited with the Bucharest Court says
the four defendants formed an
organization criminal group in 2021 to
commit human trafficking in Romania but
also in other countries including the
U.S and UK it names seven alleged
victims who said they were recruited by
the Tate Brothers through false promises
of Love and Marriage all right guys I
just I okay I need to I'm triggered
already
I have an issue with this guys in life
as women
we take L's okay I you know do you know
how many women should you know how many
women should have been human trafficked
if we're if the bar for human
trafficking is being promised marriage
a lot like as women we need to take our
L's in peace sometimes in life you take
it out you gotta move on
um but the crazy thing is let me find
this video
some of these women that were quote
unquote victims all right quote unquote
victims let me share my screen again
this is their statement
you cannot describe me
as a victim
if I'm not a victim so some of the women
that they got statements from
are saying that they do not themselves
think of themselves as victims let's
just continue
Just Like Love and Marriage
let me tell you I got
if that's the bar I then every every
girl has been human trafficked if that's
the bar
and the crazy thing is they're saying
that this criminal group
was organized in 2021 yet the Tates
stopped doing cam work
in 2017
. so it doesn't even make sense all
right so these alleged victims were
later Taken to buildings in LL five
country in Romania where they were
intimidated placed under constant
surveillance balance and control and
forced into debt according to a
statement from Romanian prosecutors
the defendants allegedly then forced the
women to take part in pornography which
was later shared on social media one of
the defendants is accused of graping
women twice in March 2022 the statement
adds the trial will not start
immediately as it is as it is expected
to take several years so guys how crazy
is it that
women with just an accusation no
evidence and texts leaked
of the women admitting to plotting
against the Tates okay there were actual
texts from these women saying they were
plotting against the Tates they can do
this and waste years of a man's life
years all right so a Romanian judge now
has 60 days to inspect the case files
before it can be sent to trial
the media team for the Tate Brothers
said while this news is undoubtedly
predictable we embrace the opportunity
it presents to demonstrate their
innocence and vindicate their reputation
it added that the indictment allows us
to present a comprehensive body of
evidence diligently collected and
prepared over time which will be which
will be undoubtedly
substitative and the brother's claim of
Innocence there are also separate
charges still under investigation which
could lead to a separate indictment
including money laundering and
trafficking of minors in 2016 Andrew
Tata British American former kickboxer
boxer was removed from the TV show Big
Brother which appeared to show him
attacking a woman
how does it appear to show him attacking
a woman either he did or like that's how
you know
I'm sorry all right you're telling me
there's a question if a kickboxer
attacked a woman a kickboxer
I'm sorry the average guy could beat me
up
average
what could a kickboxer do God only knows
uh he went on to gain notoriety with
Twitter Banning him for saying women
should bear some responsibility for
being sexually assaulted he has since
been reinstated
despite social bands he gained
popularity particularly among young men
by promoting what he presented as a
hyper masculine Ultra luxurious
lifestyle
what world
my question is what world I'm going to
check the chat what world are we living
in
years
these men will have to waste
just because a woman
was spited even though
there are videos of women coming out and
saying we love the Tate Brothers we are
not victims they are very nice guys and
the idea
I I read this on Twitter and I thought
this was really interesting so
the truth is simple one they were
extremely rich the moment the the moment
the prosecutor said they were
trafficking victims for tick tock money
Tick Tock pays between .02 and .04 guys
Tick Tock pays nothing per thousand
views imagine someone who already has
millions of dollars trafficking women
for gas money
for there of their dozens of cars insane
does that make sense to you guys
because now we're finding out that
the Tates
it wasn't about their webcam business
the whole time I thought this was about
their webcam business
which was closed in 2017 that's two the
webcam business was closed in 2017 so
it's about it's not about webcam but
about Tick-Tock three two of the victims
were whatsapping between them messages
about framing them to be famous for who
the hell raises people if they already
have or grapes people if they already
have hundreds of women throwing
themselves at them crazy people they are
not crazy
five these type of allegations process
happens to everyone
who is or was at one point telling the
truth
example Trump
so I mean guys look
is it possible that there are facts we
don't know yes is it possible that
they're
is more to the story yes
do I believe it that okay that a
multi-billionaire
millionaire whatever it is Rich guys
that have women throwing them at the
themselves at them left and right
now need traffic women
I
call me crazy I don't know call me crazy
that
they need to Grape women these guys that
have women throwing themselves at them
uh
imagine if there was a website
to be their their girlfriend whatever
like applications
do you know how many women would apply
why would someone need to do that so
we're going to tune in
on someone who I think reports a lot
more fairly
but I I'm giving you guys both sides so
don't
don't say I'm but you know I am biased
you know I I just don't I just genuinely
Tate was a nice guy I don't think he
would do that I'm not gonna pretend to
be you know best friends with the guy
but
I this all just sounds crazy to me so
there we go all right
there has been a visceral attack on
Andrew Tate by MSS MSM and alternative
media the attacks have lacked
journalistic Integrity Vice BBC and the
allegations have been debunked but they
have to have brainwashed people time to
wake up and see the truth by the way I
did a video with Vice we filmed for four
hours and they edited that [__] down to
45 minutes
45 minutes I had so many points to edit
it out
all right sorry I don't wanna sorry I'm
a woman I don't want to make this about
me all right Vice recorded a tate
documentary and shelved it but after he
was arrested the hit piece was
resurrected and the attacks began on
Twitter they inferred CPS dropped it due
to errors they intentionally didn't
highlight that two women were colluding
and refuting it was easy
Vice then produced a second article and
documentary
turned up the heat the aim was to
manipulate they provided one-sided text
messages and voice notes and didn't
include them for the girl they knew it
was consensual but that didn't work with
their agenda the attack on Tate was
manipulated to such an extent that the
members of the War Room were called for
an interview the advice were once again
exposed for using Snippets and out of
context video to further their narrative
The Barrage of MSM attacks didn't stop
NBC said Tate had beaten a woman the
link showed the opposite he acted in
self-defense the media and liberals
don't care they want to take him down
they all tried they all failed truth
stood firm and this is the thing they
can only pull this so many times guys
okay I
I'm gonna look in the hold on I'm gonna
look in the chat I was Brock Turner
innocent uh
I was thinking about this was that a me
too
was that a meat but they can only pull
the same trick so many times before
people start figuring it out you know
contrary to what the elites
think people are not stupid people are
not stupid so
the BBC attempted a hit piece and failed
miserably I didn't think it was possible
but sadly the journalistic standards
were worse than Vice they had used
chopped up Snippets of Auto context
videos to provide a negative portrayal
of Andrew Tate the BBC was so bad it
needed a second thread
they framed normal consensual
relationship with a woman into something
sinister and after this refutation
refusion they dropped out of a debate
and went into hiding they feared being
exposed and it came true
Rich Cooper and I then broke down the
many flaws misrepresentations and
Snippets and Shop videos from the BBC
journalism and dead is dead in the BBC
as an example such the level of bias
that the two victims came out and said
they were not victims
and viewed the Tate as family they were
ignored so now a woman can deny that she
was abused and the Matrix can still send
you to imagine imagine the girls coming
forward hey I'm not a victim I'm not a
victim and yet and yet
they still claim to be you know it's
like it's craziness
all right uh Tam J and I interviewed
Jasmine who clarified the Tates treated
her to like a family not a victim she's
independent extroverted and detailed
what had occurred the agenda was to
silence her so that the evidence in the
witness box would not count grape
allegations are weak the judges write no
evidence to convict
there's the woman's word versus many
witnesses and Tate they this was
disregarded to further an agenda no
evidence but the Tates imprisoned a an
extreme feminist worldview you should be
afraid
this is also the case with the human
trafficking allegations consensual
relationships framed to take out the
Tates one should be fearing falling in
love in the western liberal feminists
this can be later used by a disgruntled
partner to take you out and that's the
other thing I'm sorry
I'll give you guys
I guess two months
but like if you're coming back years
later I just
sorry I just don't
anyways
the story of the two main claimants in
the case do not stand up to scrutiny the
Moldavia dovian woman was in the sex
industry prior to meeting Tate the
relationship between the two broke down
she tried to blackmail him videos
clearly show that the woman in the U.S
had freedom of movement whilst in
romanias haters cut out Snippets of
videos despite longer versions of videos
being or indict of the indictment being
on YouTube for months she even went in
and out to get pizza then Mario posted
about the daughter of a politician
claiming Tate messaged her before she
refined her story for the BBC there were
even more flaws in the narrative
it was easy to refute
I made a thread demonstrating the double
standards of the liberal media in
relation to Tate and Greta thundberg
liberals have appointed communities to
use their pain for their own agenda a
newspaper for black issues published by
article on Tate Greta and race with zero
corrections but the liberal media sent
their army to attack me after receiving
millions of views the editor removed my
paper after two days
liberals make
minorities believe they care about them
while they use them for their goals they
use minorities to attack me with racists
and islamophobic slurs I expose their
agenda once their liberal agents fails
uh once they're liberal agents failed
most Muslims vocally or tactically
supported Tate a fringe group have been
attacking him the irony is that group is
excommuted communicated by traditional
Muslims
provided a hit piece whilst stopping all
descents their apologies supported them
they continued The Narrative you're not
allowed to speak out they canceled Tate
attacked him and canceled look guys here
here's the deal okay I think this is
pretty much done
um
okay leaks by the prosecution proved
there was no human trafficking they
showed that the woman had complete
autonomy they demonstrated that the
Tates Andrew and Tristan are innocent of
what they've been alleged here's the
crazy thing guys there are videos
released of these women luxury shopping
I wish I would I wish I would tell my
dad
that
I was trafficked after video comes out
luxury shot like just think about this
guys think about it all right these
girls
the other girls say they weren't
trafficked
these girls were luxury shopping
there's messages of them conspiring
against the Tates
and now we're just gonna believe women
w w I'm gonna read the chat guys if you
have any questions we can you know just
send whatever
but
let me play so today I tweeted I want to
go through my Twitter now
because this is the thing I keep hearing
all of the Christians and you know are
religious people whatever it is talk
about the Tates and their their cam
business right
and my my thing is people are not
perfect
so many times we go to people on social
media and just expect them to be perfect
all right we understand that the Tates
are religious now and maybe they weren't
back then this was in 2017 before they
were religious and while you might not
agree with using making a cam business
to make money and you know I would too
cam
not not my fit like I don't
not
you know I I don't condone that but
it doesn't make them criminals and it
doesn't make them bad people
so
what they're they're basically like all
the Tate people have been throwing back
this old tweet talking about how it's
gross for a guy to pay for an only fan
sorry I stand by that I I don't think
I don't know why on Earth you would do
that
um
but at the same time I support the Tates
because just because I don't like only
fans
you know oh here's my tweet the Tates
are not Gods you guys expect Perfection
out of people at the end at the end of
the day are people people make mistakes
people change it at the end of the day
cam work is not illegal so then Tristan
responds the criminal indictment States
in 2021 they formed a gang with the
purpose of kidnapping people the cam
Studio closed four years prior to this
so now we're finding out the cam work
has nothing to do with this
of the Allah seven alleged victims many
which were on our size sides how many do
you think worked for my webcam Studio
zero
he can now say things
like this because he was biting his
tongue for 15 months
yeah guys
let me go all right hold on let me go
let's go to the Tates let's go to Andrew
Tate's tweets
foreign
can we go back to the nuclear family
um
I I think we can but I I think there has
to be some consequence for decisions and
I I don't think we're ever going to have
change until women have consequences for
poor decisions which right now we're
just bailed out of everything all right
so let's see what the Tates had to say
oh let's watch this
have their friends approach them with
with magazine cover with
Amber heard's raw and emotional
testimony was at times painful to watch
I thought this is how I died
it's gonna kill me now she accused death
of brutally sexually assaulting her her
delivered quote the performance of her
life her testimony as you said has been
very emotional I think the jurors are
likely feeling sympathetic to her
heinous accusations of violence sexual
violence ridiculous humiliating
ludicrous
painful
Savage
and all false
awful he ripped my dress he's like
grabbing my my
breasts he's touching my thighs and he
rips my underwear off and then he
proceeds to do a cavity search
breaking news out off the United States
there has been a verdict in a trial
watched by millions Around the World
Virginia Jury has found that Amber Heard
defamed her ex-husband Johnny Depp has
been ordered to pay 15 million dollars
in Damages one of the most popular
athletes in the world facing allegations
of sexual assault The Wall Street
Journal reports Nike cut ties with
soccer Superstar Neymar last year in
2016 a Nike employee told friends and
colleagues that Neymar tried to force
her to perform oral sex in ajia trindade
has appeared on Brazilian TV with
accusations that she was raped he was
aggressive completely different from the
person I got to know in the messages she
claims that the incident in a Paris
Hotel last month was an assault together
with Rey police in Brazil have charged a
woman who accused the international
footballer Neymar of raping her in a
Paris Hotel in May with perverting the
course how Justice the woman and this is
why I I don't just believe women
this is why like look at this look at
this she said
well my husband have been accused of
lying to police and guys this is why you
should record everything literally
record everything
controversial influencer Andrew Tate has
been arrested in Romania on suspicion of
human trafficking rape and forming an
organized crime group I have lived with
Andrew for years
and we would never do anything like this
he is not a human tracker he would never
rape anybody I'm just so shocked and I'm
so fed up with all of these lies and he
does not deserve any of this first of
all I would like to start by saying that
there are no big things all started
April last year in 2022 when two girls
that lived in my home with me caught
themselves in their room and planned to
behold their hostage but here's the fact
when
okay so they're partying
and the police raided our homes they
forgot to mention and that's that the
key was in their room on their back the
police know that there was no crime and
they are holding the paid Brothers
locked with no evidence because they
think it's good for Romanian politics
now the other two victims that the
police claimed to be involved in this
case are me and batteries we have been
given three statements clearly saying we
are not victims but our statements keep
getting thrown away the police don't
care about the truth he said they choose
to listen to two girls that went on a
luxurious vacation on the French review
stop it a week or two after being
rescued for whatever they claimed to be
another fact is that the police threw
away the surveillance footage from the
house because they don't don't consider
it evidence evidence that proves that
those girls were able and were going for
walks they were going out of the house
with their phones whenever they wanted
wherever they wanted we want Justice to
see what's happening right now it makes
me extremely extremely upset I can say
now with confidence that these guys are
not capable of such nonsense what police
says and you say I'm Ukrainian refugee
it was Tristan who helped not only me at
6am 10 people raided my house they took
all my devices you can imagine how much
he was scared
they are purposefully trying to pressure
me to make them guilty
I can say that decode is trying to
manipulate the girls saying only what is
beneficial to them that due to lack of
evidence they are trying to extract any
information against them I am not a
victim Patrick is not a victim there are
no victims in this case and there is no
crime the prosecution has no evidence to
support their claims
and they will find no evidence that
there is no truth to this allegation
no I've never been threatened if I was
ever threatened I wouldn't be stupid
enough to stay in that house
everything you see in the news right now
is all false accusations he's always
been respectful of me and others around
him I think the media is just portraying
a really bad image of him right now and
it's not fair I think it's a little
concerning to see how easy it is for the
media to sway people into believing lies
and stuff that isn't true it if this
happens to them I am worried this can
happen to anyone at this point
[Music]
and so this is my point guys if this can
happen to a guy with money power
influence what what happens to the
average man
what happens to the average man
let's see what else we got the
the charges against Andrew and Tristan
Tate don't make much sense kidnapping
half a dozen women to force them to make
Tick-Tock video
guys I used to have a million followers
on Tick Tock almost before I got banned
I swear to God it does not pay well it
does not
uh this sounds so made up it's not even
funny Tick Tock doesn't pay well
there is no evidence in any of the
charged I agree with you I haven't been
charged but I do believe if I had to
predict the future that they will charge
me and the reason they're gonna charge
me is not because there's any evidence
or because I'm guilty but because such a
big song and dance has been made it
can't just drop it now so this battle
has just begun I believe it's gonna go
all the way to the end and soon you're
supporting me don't support me saying he
hasn't been charged support me saying we
don't see any evidence of any crime
there's no evidence
so guys you know
call me crazy
if you force seven women to make Tick
Tock videos and steal 50 of their money
how much could you make literally almost
nothing
literally almost nothing
um
and the crazy thing is they only have
one judge it's the unfortunate part in
Romania so they don't get a jury
the Tate Brothers had over a hundred
million in wealth in 2021 they allege
these crimes happened in 2021 to enrich
themselves from Tick Tock accounts
oh gosh so you know let me know in the
comments guys
what
if they were these crazy human
traffickers and you know I I can tell
you firsthand I know how much these
liberal people the woke the Matrix will
dig into their your past
you know I've had people reach out to my
family I've had people harass my family
um so if there was
any craziness that the Tates have done
don't you think they would find it don't
you think most people have a pattern of
behavior but you know call me crazy I
don't know let me know what you guys
think though in the comments
um
I just I think this is nuts
they also
how did they get 380 million US dollars
in cryptocurrency
is that true
380 million in cryptocurrency 15 luxury
cars 14 luxury watches
15 lands of building wow that's crazy
um well guys you know this is a quick
stream because you know I'm kind of
tired today but as you can see if this
happens to the Tates
what happens to the average guy is my
question
and
what evidence do they really have
against these guys and what crime have
they committed and in eight months
shouldn't they have an airtight case
I'm not gonna pretend to be an expert on
Romanian law
but I am an expert on Common Sense which
is not so common nowadays so let me know
what you guys think in the comments um
like the video on your way out let me
know do you think the Tates are innocent
do you think that they did something yes
no like the video I will talk to you
guys
uh this says story always hits me hard
because I had a similar situation I was
given a choice to plead guilty or two
years in pre-trial detention which led
me to being a fugitive and chased across
seven countries yeah let me know what
you guys think in the comments like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel and I'll talk to you next time